let's jump to the story from NPR we love
NPR guys a drone attack on Moscow
briefly shut one of its airports and
injured one take a look at this photo
there was a video I played earlier we
don't have it pulled up right now where
it's a guy driving down the highway and
he's just filming this destruction on
this building and it is terrifying stuff
they say Russian authorities say three
Ukrainian drones attacked Moscow in the
early hours on Sunday injuring one
person and prompting a temporary closure
for traffic of one of the one of four
airports around the Russian Capital it
was the fourth such attempt at a strike
on the capital region this month now I
saw some people on Twitter claim this
was a secret government uh office that
was protected by Russian Security Forces
perhaps that makes sense I don't know
why else they would strike the target
they're they're going to go after
military targets
but this is now escalation of warfare
into civilian capitals into Moscow this
is
I think there's we're starting to see um
a real case for this expanding well
beyond just a Ukrainian conflict it's
already now in Russia and where else
could it go next as is spreading there
was a news report that a Russian strike
was 600 feet from the Romanian border
which could theoretically
launch this thing just dramatically out
of control
and then Romanian NATO country
I don't know about Romania
well so I will say so I was at State
Department today and serge it's not on
Gray Zone yet but you can maybe bring it
up on the state Department's uh YouTube
channel
um I asked him about this drone strike
and and timed your point of life Romania
is as of tomorrow Romania is in NATO uh
no as of 2004 August 1st to 2023 are you
sure it says 2004 post Cold War
enlargement says alphabetical list of
NATO member countries and it says
Romania 2004. this maybe this is a typo
that's weird oh no no it's saying that
as of tomorrow is a NATO member but it
has been since o four sorry to
interruptly okay no worries
um so yeah I asked the state department
about this and and
to your point of like did Ukraine do
this I mean it was fairly obvious so
like an hour after uh this drone blows
up uh zielinski made a statement and he
says quote gradually the war is
returning to the territory of Russia to
its symbolic centers and military bases
and this is an inevitable natural and
absolutely Fair process zielinski said
that and he's explicitly said we're
targeting symbolic centers
um which to me I could only mean you
know areas where civilians gather so it
sounds like we're targeting civilians
and I asked the state department this
and um he basically said well I don't
know if that's what symbolic centers
means and then he brushed it off and
wouldn't let me get a follow-up in but
um to me when you make a speech like
that an hour after the explosion happens
that kind of looks like you're taking
credit for it
um and so it's extremely scary I mean
it's crazy that the US I mean we keep
like U.S officials keep saying like well
we don't support attack we don't support
attacks on Russia's border well it's
like well you keep funding them and
arming them to do it so at what point
are you gonna like you know enforce your
um lack of support for attacking
Russia's border and um you know it's
just scary I mean this word civilians on
the ground in Ukraine and the U.S
providing weapons which end up in the
hands of many of these people
like Russia knows full well what's going
on when it comes to this strike on
Russian targets Russia's not going oh
those ukrainians read it again they're
saying NATO just attacked our capital
so this is this seems like the only path
the only path forward is going to be
escalation it could be a false flag
could be Russian drones doing it doesn't
matter either way the same thing happens
if it's a false flag then Russia wants
to escalate and it's even worse but if
it was a false flag why would zielinski
come out an hour later and basically be
like hey we're going after symbolic
centers I guess
um you'd be like if you were the
commander and then some random elements
within your country bombed some random
elements within the enemy country you'd
be like see there you go American great
yes let me bring you back to the era of
piracy where there would be privateers
and corsairs who would receive letters
of Mark from their government to disrupt
the enemy's supply lines and then let's
say it was the English and the French
the French would capture a pirate ship
running Black Sails or whatever a black
flag and then these guys are clearly
British they'd go to the crown and say
we know that you are ransacking our
trade lines oh how dare you we would
never condone piracy all the the oh I'm
offended
that's what they do so what's going on
right now it is the most
annoying thing everyone these officers
are like the US is not involved in war
those are volunteers I'm like shut up
defectively the same thing no one's Stu
like you can believe whatever you want
to believe so that you can sleep at
night but I assure you Joe Biden Kamala
Harris Milly whoever it may be is under
No Illusion that we are not involved in
this they know exactly what they're
funding and Russia is the exact same in
the Vietnam War it was the Americans
versus the Russians basically right
versus the Russians and the Chinese
maybe but for somehow we just never came
to blows with Russia we'd never even
talked about it as if it was against
Russia we did we call it proxy war yeah
they were funding the Viet Cong in the
North Vietnamese U.S Middle Eastern
involvement was proxy war against uh
very much so Russia and to a certain
Chinese yeah that was yeah against the
Soviets Soviets and that's what that's
what Syria is our support for the rebel
groups it's because Syria would not side
with us because they're allied with
Russia so of course anyone in government
aligned with Russia we opposed so
convenient I'm like did Isis was there
were they funded by the Russians
like you would think if the Russians
were really our enemies they would have
been funding Isis remember that
happening this is why they were happy
when Trump decimated Isis when Trump
started taking them out Putin's like
this is good yeah
it was good for both and then they
claimed that the reason Putin didn't
invade Ukraine was because Donald Trump
was catering to Putin's interests and
I'm like yeah
destroying Isis not getting us involved
in Wars wow it's almost like he was
doing with the American people yeah well
actually and he armed Ukraine with a
bunch of weapons too so that's true
which is obviously not in Russia's
interest
um there was also a tweet on this
explosion this account tweets it out and
they're like oh my God drones hitting
Moscow how unfortunate and then like a
little sunglasses emoji meaning like you
know we like this and then the General
Michael Hayden who's the former director
of the CIA and NSA tweets out tweets out
oh it's an act of God like about this
explosion there's like you can watch the
video there's like this woman who's
screaming she's in Terror it's like a
horrible video to watch and the former
um director of the cin NSA is like
celebrating this on Twitter it is it is
insane of course
um I I don't it's like that shark attack
where there was the shark attack and
people were like happy because some
Russian dude got eaten by a shark but
who has nothing to do with the war it's
like
um people who don't realize that it's
the government's perpetrating these wars
and like you know most of these soldiers
are conscripted anyways it's like you
should be mad at the governments even if
you um you know believe uh the whole
narrative around Ukraine you should be
mad at Putin and the government you
don't don't celebrate like civilians
getting bombed in Moscow what do you
think what do you think is a just
solution to the war I I
um I mean I I think the war could have
been avoided in the first place by
um giving up uh or holding referendums
in which by the way zielinski campaigned
on this
he campaigned on holding referendums in
the Doane bus in Crimea because there
was like a decade-long civil war in the
Don moss and of course Russia basically
controls Crimea and and this Civil War
was awful and so and poroshenko's by the
end of like by zelinski when he was
campaigning in 2019
poroshenko's approval rating was so low
because of this war it was like people
didn't people didn't want to fight this
war and and that's why also the azov
Battalion which is kind of the the
Neo-Nazi sect
um grew you know so much stronger is
because people didn't the only people
who wanted to fight were those guys
but so zelinski campaigns and he's like
I'm gonna hold referendums in the dome
bus I'm going to let them decide whether
they want autonomy whether they want a
secede or be in Ukraine and he wins
overwhelming he wins like 75 of the vote
and in the East everyone voted for him
in the in the general election
then he gets in and he doesn't do it he
seemed open to it you can actually look
there's like oh there's like Biden 2021
White House statements where Biden is
like saying like no no Crimea is Ukraine
we're going to stick to this in zelenski
earlier had been like well I'm still
open to referendums there but then Biden
makes gets involved and it's like no no
crime is Ukraine
um Boris Johnson was sent in and crushed
a piece yeah that was after the war but
so in terms of like a a a peace
agreement could have been
just hold referendums in the dawn bus in
Crimea Crimea overwhelmingly even by
like U.S government conducted polls in
2014 Crimea overwhelmingly wants to join
Russia the Doan boss it's not clear
whether they want to join or secede or
want more like just governing autonomy
um from Kiev
just just hold those referendums and see
what happens that that was Putin's
demand before he invaded and you could
have just granted that and people say
like well you can't do that because then
he'll just be even closer and he'll keep
going but it's like take the chance on
it then at least or or like negotiate
some I don't know negotiate something
better but like like the idea that this
counterfactual is like well Putin would
have gone even further it's like well
guess what like hundreds of thousands
have died Ukraine is destroyed and
millions are now refugees because like
of that counterfactual that you're so
sure of it's like we could have held
these referendums and we and we
potentially could have avoided the
entire war and we still could we still
could do that now I think if Donald
Trump gets elected the day they call it
for Trump the hour the minute the war
stops
yeah I mean I think he would probably do
maybe some form of what I just said I
don't know I just think the moment they
say and the winner of the 2024
presidential election is projected to be
Donald Trump Russia immediately says
ceasefire and zelinsky too will be like
finally the dogs are off my back I can
do what I want with my country like if
so maybe I think some of the dogs on his
back are kind of the far right guys
within his own uh within his own
government but Putin stops right away
because he wants more leverage so Putin
is probably going to be saying Trump's
going to come in he's going to end this
we're not going to get everything we
want we'll get enough of what we want
but if we're still fighting it's not
we'll gain more leverage by stopping the
fighting right now then and then you
know uh brushing up to to Trump's ego
and being like we knew that as soon as
you got in you were going to be
reasonable and help us end this conflict
so we pulled our troops back Trump's
going to be like absolutely here's what
I expect it's over 100 I mean I think
that's true of not only Trump I think
that's true of RFK and vivec as well
um agreed
um but I I also think like Trump winning
is just a massive a fantasy I mean I
think
um
we I I can't recite like the whole
history I know I know a couple
interesting facts about the whole JFK
assassination and to me it's
overwhelming that the CIA killed him so
Donald Trump won in 2016. well he won
and then you know
um the intelligence agencies
um well I guess Hillary and and her team
fabricated the dossier and then
um this kind of they tied stones to
Trump's feet exactly and and but but if
you if you think do you really think
he's going to be allowed in with like
the stated goal of like getting revenge
of the deep state or do you think they
might just pull the trigger at some
point well I don't know about any of
that I mean RFK has talked about the
risk you know based on his family
history so perhaps and there's been
other people who have speculated
horrifying things may happen but uh look
if if I believe that if Donald Trump is
harmed this country implodes overnight
I mean it's it's chaos Beyond chaos if
something happens to Trump in that in
that capacity not an option well I think
what's terrifying about that when you
take the left would believe it the left
would be like yeah people hate Trump no
but that's why that's why you're so
correct it's like the left would believe
that they'd be like yeah everyone hates
Trump of course someone would
assassinate but the right is going to be
like no yeah exactly and then it doesn't
matter right that's gonna cause chaos so
you you have to ask yourself why the why
the United States has not say
assassinated Julian Assange when Hillary
Clinton reporter said can we just drown
this guy and they're like yeah he's in
London right why
certain people they got no problem with
maybe it's a 16 year old American
citizen Barack Obama's like we're gonna
blow him up because his dad's a
terrorist so they kill Abdullahi in a
civilian restaurant in a country we're
not at war with Trump killed his son
though too Trump killed or his uh his
daughter his daughter now see
hypothetically I don't know that that I
that is a claim made by the family
whereas the Drone strike on something
restaurant is confirmed by the U.S
government and another thing that's it's
one thing to catch around in a gun fight
and it's another thing to have someone
shoot a missile at like the daughter but
investigate Trump yeah fine I don't care
if this is collateral damage and an
American girl died he's responsible for
that yeah presidents should be allowed
to get away with this stuff especially
when we're not at war with this country
but uh but fair point right you know
Barack Obama was like blow him up yes he
I mean Barack Obama had his actual kill
list like list of people but they
claimed they were targeting a different
guy and he was an actor was it oops we
got the wrong guy but you know
convenient wolves but yeah yeah you know
so I don't I think
if something happened to Donald Trump
this country gets ripped apart in two
seconds and the reason why they don't go
after people like doing this on just
because they don't want to make Martyrs
you you will make that man Immortal and
only in his best features yeah yeah I
feel like they'll be some behind the
scenes Shenanigans to keep him out of
office before an assassination for that
same reason he's too powerful
metaphorically I agree with that I'm
just saying if there's a chance he's
gonna get into office though
what I find fascinating I think is that
Roseanne says there's not going to be an
election
and I had to ask her to clarify because
Michael Mouse said of course there will
be
but I think it's probably a mix of the
two perspectives there will be an
election but no one will care no one
will accept it no one you think 2020 was
bad 2024 is going to
beat it's just gonna be nuts it's gonna
be bad because now after 2020 you're
gonna have every single Trump supporter
filming everything you are going to have
a hundred times as many videos coming
out showing weird things that may be
innocuous maybe nothing or maybe
suspicious
and no matter who wins or who loses the
other side will refuse we saw the Boston
Globe story where powerful Democrats
suggested the West Coast secede from the
union event in the event Donald Trump
gets elected that's how crazy they are
now what do you think happens if Trump
loses again
this time there's going to be people
everywhere filming literally everything
I thought 2020 was going to be more
chaotic than it was
Maybe I'm Wrong about 2024. but I just
don't see anyone accepting the results
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time